all right we're doing a quick hit today
to help highlight someone who's fighting
these insane lockdowns as hopefully you
are
in your own little way i'll be sitting
down with anton the owner of nick the
greek restaurant in ventura county
and you probably recognize him because
he's the guy who stood up to government
regulators trying to shut down his
business i'm going to throw to the viral
video that has been seen millions of
times already and then we're going to go
right into my interview with anton so
first take a look at the video
i'm aware i friday night you guys came i
put my tables inside i've been tired of
everything that you guys have told
me too and yes you guys can even it
should be a warning
and and and they're trying to shut me
out right when i'm complying with you
so the restaurant is shut down okay
so let's go i'm gonna turn this
restaurant down okay that's why we're
here
okay okay
okay so uh we have a closure temporary
suspension of the permit here
okay we're not supposed to be open we
were suspended on friday
the order was issued by public health
that says that
we need to close until we can get rios
me is because on friday evening as a
protest which i'm allowed to do
i put tables outside i sold all my food
to go i didn't
i didn't do any outdoor dining i start
all my future goals and it was
everybody's own prerogative
to sit outside on my tables again as
protests which i'm allowed to do
okay now you guys came friday evening
and your two thousand we were friday
evening basically said listen if you put
your tables and chairs inside right now
you're in compliance i said okay can i
make it go buy it
why would you shut me down then and they
said because it's really gone through
your guy's
system and now i have to wait for you
guys to come back
before i before but i can open
complying with you and i have the tables
and chairs inside
you want me and are forcing you to shut
down my business
and i have to send all my employees home
i have rent to pay i have bills to pay
and
this is what it's about
support to you guys when we start this
past action lawsuit
with all these restaurants against the
elf department we have all the proof
right here on film
right anton we just showed the viral
clip it's very obvious to me that not
all heroes wear
capes you you stood up to the man man
how you feeling
uh yeah you did um uh i mean that that
that video was not i had no intention of
that video going viral
that was that was literally just my
emotion in the time
um that that happened and it was just
just so happened to be that that guy
the guy jorge ventura i was just coming
out of an interview with him
um and those health inspectors were
there so um
as my reaction came out with the health
inspectors he uh he was filming the
whole video and that's that's how it
went viral
um there was two inspectors that that
were there there was a lady and a guy
uh my strong feeling is if if it was
just a lady there
it would have gone a completely
different way um and just because she
was very calm she was really trying to
get the facts and figure out everything
that was going on
um and it even in the beginning sound
like she was like okay like let me try
to figure this out to like help you out
type of thing
whereas when that guy opened his mouth
he just like was this
aggressive like he came across as this
like aggressive macho person
um and that really like kind of set it
off for me because i was like excuse me
like
like what does this doesn't make any
sense um
and the main the main thing and the main
thing with me is is i don't like when
people don't stick to their word
right so so the story started on last
friday i spoke to a supervisor at the
health department
and i was like listen i'm going to put
my tables out as a protest
i'm still going to serve all my food to
go i'm not going to actually serve
people outside i'm going to serve it all
to go
let me protest for whatever four hours
that evening
and and just just let me do that and i'm
allowed to do that by law
uh right now you're allowed you're
allowed to protest
um and he was fine with that he was like
you know what if you're just gonna do it
for this evening and that night that's
fine
so i said all right great um and this is
when he didn't stick to his word because
that evening around 7
30 two health inspectors came and
they're like listen we're gonna have to
give you a closure notice
and i'm like look look i understand uh
that i'm not following the rules right
now because i put my tables outside but
it was as a protest so let me take them
inside right now and let's just
forget about all this you don't need to
give me a closure notice because i'm i'm
going to follow your rules now
and they're like okay okay let me talk
to her let's talk to her let me talk to
our supervisor so they called the
supervisor came back and said nope we
still have to order you a closure notice
and by this time i'd already put all my
tables inside
and i'm following your rules now why are
we still going to go down this route
so uh what ended up happening was you're
like
yeah you're going to have to contact the
health department to be able to reopen
again i said well today's friday night
you guys aren't open on saturday and
sunday i'm not closing my
for saturday and sunday because i have
bills to pay you know um
so so i ended up leaving my business
open uh saturday sunday monday morning
that same supervisor called me and i
said hey listen man last time we talked
you didn't stick your words i'm gonna
record this conversation which is
exactly what i did i recorded the
the conversation and um basically the
conversation led to the fact where he
was like look if you put to me on an
email that you're going to continue
complying
you're going to continue to have your
chairs and tables inside and continue to
serve only to go in for delivery
he's like you can reo i'll reinstate you
you can re reopen back again i said all
right well this time i'm filming and
recording you so you better keep your
word
he's like yes i will so i sent him that
email a few minutes after i said look
i'm gonna comply
fine let me go about my business let's
just drop this whole thing
and two hours later he uh he comes back
with an email says actually you know
what because we heard that you were open
on saturday and sunday
uh you're gonna have to remain closed
now oh god i'm like look man
and when i got that email that's when i
was already like this is the second time
this guy's not stuck to his word and
he's
again so um and that's the exact time
that
jorge ventura was interviewing me and
that's the exact time those two health
inspectors came in so my
my my emotion was already at its highest
because of that email that came in so
just that's
that's how it went okay so first off
basically the guy's lying to you
and you have to stay open on the
weekends because it's hard enough to
to make ends meet at this point was
anyone even sitting at your tables
outside and again you weren't serving
them out there you were saying okay you
take it to go
and then there's a seat there if you
happen to sit there i think people are
still allowed to sit outdoors but was
anyone even using those seats
yeah so on that i said yeah some people
were sitting out on the table some
people were sitting on a curb people
were kind of sitting wherever they
wherever they could
to eat their food um and again that's
not
that and and the health department's
like well you're responsible for that i
don't feel
and i am not responsible for other human
beings i also don't have the right to go
up to somebody and tell them what to do
it's that's not in my right it's not
my right at all so that's the whole
point is like their their
their way of thinking is just out of
this world it makes no sense it's
so i'm gonna go around now and start
telling people you can't do this and can
do that
that's that's not in my right yeah you
would make a very terrible government
regulator obviously
if you don't think that's within your
right so can you just talk about just
generally like you got a smile on your
face right now but you you have to be
seriously frustrated with what's going
on here i know you have a couple
locations we ordered in from my whole
team from the uh from the la location
and you guys make great food
um can you just talk about just the the
general frustrations that you
that all restaurants are all
restauranteurs are feeling right now
the biggest frustration right now the
reason why people are really
lashing out right now is because over
the summer when they when they
shut everything down the government was
giving money weekly to people
they were doing the pbp loans for
businesses so everybody could continue
on paying their bills because
the economy is continuing to move
forward this time around
they're shutting down restaurants and
they're not gonna give us any ppp money
they're not
gonna help our employees out by giving
them money weekly so it's like well
how do you expect my employees to go pay
for their rent how do you expect me to
pay for my rent
i mean it's just it's a chain reaction
and chain effect that's that makes no
sense and is not fair at all
especially with big box stores and when
you walk into any costco
lowe's home depot i mean there's a ton
of people in there i
it really does not look like they're
controlling that whole twenty percent
or twenty five percent occupancy in
those stores and it just so happens to
be because
those stores aren't controlled by the
health department
restaurants are controlled by the health
department and which i also don't even
know if it's in the
right to control the outdoor seating
because
health department is supposed to be for
the health of or for the food and safety
or the safety of the food in a
restaurant to make sure that
people are not getting sick that's the
job of a health department with a
restaurant
um not to go around saying you can't you
can't have people sitting outside that's
that's never been part of their job
yeah did you happen to see that video of
the the health inspector guy
in in la basically saying that we know
that outdoor dining
doesn't spread the disease but we just
want to keep people at home did you
happen to catch that video
oh no i didn't say that that's i didn't
see it but that makes yeah that's
that's the whole thing it's not
scientifically proven that outdoor
dining
uh spreads covet faster than anything
else so and that's the whole thing is
everyone just wants a level playing
field right so it's like okay if you're
gonna shut things down shut everybody
down
if you're not then don't shut everybody
down and let us all continue i mean you
you can't again you can't have this
unlevel playing field where
where all these other stores are making
a ton of money and and we're not
but having said that mom and pop like
clothing stores that are on
main street in ventura they're feeling
their revenue also dipping right now why
because people aren't coming downtown to
eat so they're also not coming downtown
to shop
well it's not only affecting us it's
affecting other retailers you know
are you gonna stay in a in california
that's the million-dollar question that
i get asked a hundred times a day but
like
as a business guy as someone trying to
you know
do something good and and put out a good
product but having to deal with these
guys like
do you think about getting out of here
yeah i do um i just have
a growth plan for the restaurants right
now within uh within california
um and and with everything going on i
still hope that i can continue to hit it
this is most likely gonna hinder that
but um if i am able to hit it
most likely once i'm once once i've got
once i've reached my goal then i
probably will be moving to uh
to a different state not unless
california starts changing but i mean
you look at
elon musk as has moved tesla's moved uh
oracle's moved all these
and and the crazy thing to me is is is i
don't understand and see how
um how how they're all the money that's
coming into california because of these
companies that's now
not going to be because it's going
somewhere else on all these people that
they were employing
i mean how do they see the future uh
going along you know
it's uh it's really tough well listen
man i i know you didn't ask for this
fight but you're in it now
and anything i can do to help just let
me know one more thing i want to say
is the the officials that are
controlling things right now
are the same type of people which i find
completely ridiculous as when
back when they tried to shut tesla down
and there was that government official
letter and said [ __ ] elon musk or [ __ ]
you elon musk
like who does that yeah especially if
you're trying to portray yourself in a
leadership position
you don't do that i mean and that's
basically those are the type of people
that are trying to control us
like that's it's it's completely out of
this world and ridiculous in my opinion
anton you want to run for governor
people want me to run for governor i
feel like i feel like
you're better suited come on i don't
think i don't
i don't think i can take that on man
politics is a whole different uh
different ball game i'll stick to the
business of being an entrepreneur
all right stick to the falafel in the
meantime all right well listen anything
anything i can do to help i'm not just
saying it you got my number so just let
me know
and let we'll just keep the spotlight on
you guys and i wish you luck
dave one uh sorry this is really the
last thing i want to say
you're saying anything that you can do
to help what i'd love for you to do
is uh because we've gone viral we've got
so much support from
literally people in different states
calling in and ordering food to support
us
and also trying to donate if you could
go out and tell
all of the us and these same people hey
listen
don't only do that to nick the greek
start calling up random restaurants in
california and do those good
deeds to all the restaurants because
again my whole point from the get-go was
to help
restaurants as a whole this wasn't for
me and this wasn't for nick the greek
this is for the whole thing so
if all these people can call up random
restaurants in california and just start
ordering food i mean that'd be that'd be
amazing and and that's how you can
help spread that because you have the
audience so i'm on it man you're a true
american thanks for taking the time
now get back to work for god's sakes
all right see ya if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell